I ended up without time for the story yesterday,
but it is important and I did want to talk
about it
with you.
So two days ago, Donald Trump during what
was day three officially or although kind
of day two as we knew it, but officially day
three on Wednesday of his Senate impeachment
trial, he went on Twitter and he appeared
to admit to concealing evidence, which is
an example of obstructing Congress, which
is something he's already being impeached
for.
Uh, this is Donald Trump speaking from the
world economic forum in Davos, Switzerland.
This is the same place where he went after
17 year old climate activist Gretta Toon Berg,
which we discussed on yesterday's program.
Trump talking about how he has the material
and they meaning Democrats, the house impeachment
managers don't have the material, which means
he's concealing evidence if he's indeed telling
the truth.
Here.
When we released that conversation, all hell
broke out with the Democrats because they
say, wait a minute, this is much different
than shifty.
Schiff told us.
So we're doing very well.
I got to watch enough.
I thought our team did a very good job, but
honestly we have all the material, they don't
have the material, we
have the material, they don't have the material.
If we're understanding Donald Trump and if
he's telling the truth, it's always possible
with Trump that either we're not understanding
him because he's difficult to understand or
that he's simply lying.
He seems to be admitting to withholding evidence
from house impeachment managers.
And by the way, Donald Trump also lying in
that clip for sure even though it's only 23
seconds.
Donald Trump also managing to lie and again
falsely claim that he released the phone call
transcript.
He did not release the phone call transcript.
The phone call was about 30 33 minutes long
going from memory.
The transcript portion that was released seemed
to consist of somewhere between six and nine
minutes of that 30 to 33 minute phone call.
But he keeps repeating and his attorneys keep
repeating and Republicans keep repeating.
We saw the transcript and it was fine and
it was a perfect phone call.
They did not, and it wasn't, and we would
love to see the transcript.
And by the way, I would love to hear audio
of the perfect phone call, but back to the
material that Donald Trump has.
This is their strategy and they've been rewarded
for this strategy.
We talked about this a lot on yesterday's
program.
They've ignored subpoenas simply saying, we're
not going to do it.
Uh, he's crediting the strategy of ignoring
subpoenas and withholding as the reason why
he's doing well in the impeachment trial.
Every single time Congress requests something
Trump and his lawyers Stonewall or they just
don't do it.
They're asked to produce documents.
They don't.
They try to block witnesses.
They try to prevent witnesses from testifying.
This is obstruction of Congress, which Donald
Trump is bragging about doing and he's doing
it in order to obstruct an impeachment trial,
partially for obstructing Congress.
I guess the upside is if you're already impeached
for obstruction of Congress, you can't be
double impeached for obstruction of Congress.
I don't know.
And the sickest part is that it's going to
work.
Trump has don't care about Donald Trump actually
being exonerated in a fair trial.
We talked about how on day one of actually
before day one, well depends on what you call
day one but before opening arguments even
started, you had both Donald Trump's lawyers
and house impeachment managers saying for
this to really carry weight for an acquittal
or an a or a conviction to really mean something,
it needs to be a full and fair trial.
And, and if you're the house impeachment managers,
that means it has to include documents, it
has to include witnesses, and the reality
is they're wrong.
Trump doesn't care about actually having a
fair trial because Trumpists don't care about
having a fair trial.
They will see a kangaroo court return, a sham
acquittal.
We learned 40% of Republicans weren't even
in the chamber during much of a Adam shifts
opening arguments two days ago.
They will see this bogus sham acquittal that's
been preconceived already and they will consider
it an exoneration.
Even though Donald Trump's handling of his
impeachment is arguably impeachable and he'll
be acquitted and potentially reelected in
November of 2020.
Just look at what's happened before.
He admitted to obstructing justice on national
television and on Twitter and nothing happened.
We say this guy appears to be untouchable
and he seems to actually be right.
He, he believes he's untouchable and so far
he's been untouchable.
He publicly intimidates witnesses on Twitter
and through, um, uh, subordinates tampering
with witnesses, gets away with it.
He sees himself as untouchable because he's
been affectively untouchable.
And the only thing to do, I mean, it's an
indictment of our justice system.
It's our, it's an indictment of the state
of checks and balances, but the only thing
we have left is to vote in November, as I
said yesterday, in such large numbers that
it would be difficult to manipulate into a
Trump win period.
The chance of an indictment essentially ended
when impeachment began.
It's sad.
It's horrible to admit these Republicans won't
even consider it.
I was hoping maybe, you know, when we hear
there might be five Republicans who might,
might be willing to do the right thing.
Maybe they could convince others.
It's just not going to be what the Republican
party cares to do here.
It's, it's not.
We've lost checks and balances.
The only one left is an Oh, it's not just
a win in November.
It has to be an overwhelming win.
So overwhelming that foul play and tricks
and interference and voting machine nonsense
and all of it can't get them reelected.
And once again, I'm opening the floor.
If you think there's any chance of a conviction
in this Senate trial, I want to hear from
you.
I don't know if there's anyone left in my
audience who thinks we might see a conviction
here.
I saw that the betting odds, uh, at one point
had about 12% of the money saying there could
be a, there will be a conviction that was
down to 7% a couple of days ago.
I don't know where it is right now.
If there's anyone in my audience who thinks
we might see a conviction, by all means, please
get in touch and tell me what will happen